hello how reject nation
Greg Albie here jonald we're gonna watch
a deleted scene from infinity war what
yay real quick I want to say thank you
to everyone who's been joining our
patreon page lately because we've gotten
quite a bit a few pledges lately so much
fun over there we actually post a hell
of a lot our main thing that we do is
actually full-length TV show reactions I
personally cover attack on Titan did
most of the episodes of season 4 of the
flash started up Gotham
John covers Riverdale Atlanta Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood to start up
channel zero together we do Cobra Kai my
hero academia few episodes Jessica Jo
season two left and a few episodes no
one episode of black lightning and of
course weekly Q&A is a music video
coverage so hey would love to have you
become a patron object today people can
anything helping keeping this channel
afloat right now anyway let's get to
this this clip is called Guardians
fighting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the coded message channel was just been
on a blinking yellow indicates an
important secret coded message this is
your job
it was his job if it was yellow let it
Mellow brown flush it down those were
your orders 22 important coded secret
messages five hours
I've been sitting five hours we have 22
messages 23 messages oh I keep coming in
from nebula Gamora is alive
danos is taking her that's how I found I
did
this kind of made me just go that
there's probably so many deleted seeds
that you could have made a like an hour
episode out of each one of these
individual storylines there's probably a
yes because that was a full-on scene
that they had there I'm glad they cut it
out I mean it's a useful piece of
information even though it did see
infinity war three times in the theaters
I don't remember if they establish how
they found Titan I just figured that
would be a good guess
yeah found some coordinates attracted I
don't know I kind of just filled in the
blank of my other NAB sure they figured
it out some way that made sense in the
movie yeah things you willingly forgive
and fill in for yourself because I know
they got a bigger fish to fry that does
make it better to know that it was
nebula who sent that I really don't
remember in the movie if they if they
said it or not I'm glad they cut the
scene out I think it would have slowed
down the pacing of the film also Drax I
especially didn't like in guardians -
yeah I had some really funny lines for
sure at the same time though I hate how
he's just become an idiot he's just a
joke character rather than a character
character late is a character who blames
and he's a character who's stupid a lot
of the time and then here that just
would have solidified that for me yeah
like oh my god you're so dumb like the
message is part if I was in the movie
theater that would have annoyed me for
just some joke about pee and poop yeah
that would have been like that actually
would have gotten on my nerves in the
actual movie itself in the movie he's
not that useful either in the film he
does attack on impulse and makes a lot
of noise which was not good in that
seemed like yeah this was a good idea
was cut but it was cool to see another
scene of the Guardians it would make
sense for them to kind of go into blame
mode after losing one of the people they
loved to Thanos yeah totally well in
watching this I was sort of thinking
that like I'm not exactly sure where
this would have smoothly fit into the
movie it feels like a sidebar scene and
I mean it was amusing to watch here I
mean it's it's unfinished and I feel
like it was definitely lacking score of
some kind amusing but not much more than
that and yeah I'm pretty pleased or I'm
fine
they cut it you know and another thing
it does clitter up you know for all
Peter knew it the more could have been
dead solidifies them this is his way of
knowing for sure that Kimura still alive
ray of hope yeah exactly so that would
have added a little bit I don't know I
did this really is a scene where I'm not
upset that they cut it out at all yeah
I'm glad they actually cut it happen
yeah yeah totally I mean the best
argument could you could make for it I
think is just that it kind of helps to
flash a little blaze yeah just vibes
that come into play later on in the
movie the deterioration of Peter quill I
don't know if this specific scene would
have softened the blow that upset a lot
of people myself included when Peter
does attack Thanos and ultimately makes
them fail their mission to get the glove
I was on the side that I'm like I get it
but I'm annoyed I don't know if having
this moment would have had that moment
to make more sense or not I guess I
would have to see it in the entirety of
the runtime of almost three hour and a
nuke understand where's the Russo cut
it's still fun can't wait to buy this
movie that's for sure you're gonna have
you have three times I'm definitely
gonna be watching it more it's gonna be
amazing on the small screen oh yeah the
wait is meant to be watch gonna
completely erase my memory of the IMAX
experience oh it's crazy with a
television experience it's really cool
the way the aspect ratio changes from
the bars on top to not have equality
yeah
well guys thanks for watching you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check us out
on patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A s and music video coverage
more also would love to have you become
a patron ejecta die